[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a good one.
Just label that for just there.
Oh, yeah.
I was like a deer.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_14]: I already have a blank template for Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_14]: So that is the pledge period.
[SPEAKER_14]: I want to see the agenda.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's see the 24th.
[SPEAKER_11]: At 1130.
[SPEAKER_11]: Can you move those calendars so we can look at it and now we follow up with that?
[SPEAKER_14]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_14]: It's crazy.
[SPEAKER_11]: Maybe on Monday to see if we can send it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll do this for you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Just, you know, something like kind of like just, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Something very, just a little bit.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
It does
[SPEAKER_10]: We got a contract for the main dance, Missouri Typewriter.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can see, like she uses Toshiba.
[SPEAKER_02]: We've owned ours for a long time.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I can see from the writer is based on those.
[SPEAKER_11]: Now, we're talking about the one.
I need a motion to approve.
[SPEAKER_06]: I need somebody.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because if you did ask.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because they need a big, do they need one that does big stuff?
[SPEAKER_06]: I have no idea on that.
We're going to have to figure it out.
We'll have to figure it out.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, I'll call them a certain time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because they do all the maintenance on the machine, it's so thick and maybe, you know, that's who they got it from.
[SPEAKER_10]: So that's already ready, and I have it right here.
[SPEAKER_10]: Kind of like that one on there.
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I guess the same.
[SPEAKER_06]: Really, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll call them and find out.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then if they do, I'll let them know what you guys want.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I've got our queue prepared.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want me to copy it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I haven't set it up to run it yet.
[SPEAKER_14]: This one, I have it over here.
[SPEAKER_14]: Amy sent this, and I pinned it to her.
[SPEAKER_14]: This is a middle school agreement for Henry.
[SPEAKER_14]: You already know that.
[SPEAKER_14]: Scientists want us to be able to show you all that they want additional insight, and they want to do something about this.
[SPEAKER_14]: I was proud that she was working out for us.
[SPEAKER_14]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to see what he does.
[SPEAKER_03]: Allison Acres.
[SPEAKER_03]: What?
[SPEAKER_03]: Allison?
[SPEAKER_03]: Allis, O-L-O-I-S, Allison Acres.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's see if she's ready.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't want to do that again.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've had that before and it's no good.
[SPEAKER_14]: Apparently there's some virus going around that gives you vertigo or sore throat.
[SPEAKER_12]: We're going to have to start reading the emails.
[SPEAKER_14]: That's the road bridge.
[SPEAKER_14]: I just click on it and I can see who's made a complaint for roads.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Where is it?
[SPEAKER_05]: And this automatically goes to... Yep.
[SPEAKER_14]: It goes to Clay, too.
[SPEAKER_14]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_14]: So I don't have to worry about that.
[SPEAKER_14]: You don't have to worry about that.
[SPEAKER_14]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_14]: I only have it pinned because they don't like it.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is going to be bare bones.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's going to be bare bones.
[SPEAKER_14]: Oh, thank you.
[SPEAKER_14]: I didn't see that.
[SPEAKER_14]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_14]: Okay, I believe that it is straight up 9 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_11]: Do we have a motion?
[SPEAKER_11]: is now in session.
[SPEAKER_11]: Do we have any comments from public?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Kurt Croy, I just want to, last week you said, Max, that you were waiting still to get that piece of equipment.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wonder if that came in.
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah, it had, we got a call on it the other day.
[SPEAKER_10]: It had flaking on the hydraulic cylinders.
[SPEAKER_01]: I haven't forgotten.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we are being recorded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, the other thing was as I've been out walking around talking to people about my campaign, one of the volunteer...
[SPEAKER_01]: volunteers at the last election in April I went and audited just watching what was going on and they said that after that they got a call from the county and were questioned about me being there so I'm wondering why was it a problem that I was at the election trying to see what was going on or why did that happen because they felt like they got in trouble from the county for just allowing
[SPEAKER_11]: I'm not aware of exactly what went on, except I know there are very strict, stringent rules about what goes on.
[SPEAKER_11]: And I don't know exactly what those things were.
[SPEAKER_11]: But, I mean, Heather, do you want to comment?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, so when it comes to elections like that, nobody's allowed to touch the election equipment.
[SPEAKER_05]: or even around the election equipment, unless you're sworn in as election judge.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we were told that you actually had had your hands on the machine itself.
[SPEAKER_05]: And that is a total no-no.
[SPEAKER_03]: Enter here to the motion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Enter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whenever I was there, the election officials had me unplug the machine while they were doing teardown.
[SPEAKER_01]: as the only thing that I touch, so that's not election interference.
[SPEAKER_14]: I think the state's investigating it.
[SPEAKER_14]: We're not doing anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so there was a problem with me being there auditing the election.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, well, it's news to me because nobody's contacted me.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, thank you.
[SPEAKER_11]: Any other comments, Cindy?
[SPEAKER_11]: Do you have anything?
[SPEAKER_11]: Any questions?
[SPEAKER_12]: It looks nice out there with the new cement.
[SPEAKER_12]: Is the grass going to be seeded?
[SPEAKER_12]: They did a great job.
[SPEAKER_12]: Yeah, they did.
[SPEAKER_12]: Very nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: We can never get grass to grow there.
[SPEAKER_11]: and it does not grow it's just awfully shaded i mean we're aware of it and we would like to do we would like to do several things there to make that
[SPEAKER_11]: nicer and prettier.
[SPEAKER_11]: But we did make some big steps.
[SPEAKER_12]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_12]: I'm not complaining.
[SPEAKER_12]: I'm just wondering.
[SPEAKER_12]: We see it too.
[SPEAKER_12]: I want palm trees and flowers.
[SPEAKER_12]: Maybe a reflecting pool.
[SPEAKER_12]: An ocean.
[SPEAKER_14]: An ocean!
[SPEAKER_14]: But when the last thing was to pull out all those bushes, you know, what you used to line the sidewalks, they never filled the dirt back in when you took the bushes out.
[SPEAKER_14]: So that might be something that
[SPEAKER_11]: So I think that baby steps seems like.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay, then I think that we are nothing else.
[SPEAKER_11]: I will say Bree, today is your last day.
[SPEAKER_11]: You're going to be gone at noon today and we're going to miss you.
[SPEAKER_11]: We wish you well and hope that
[SPEAKER_14]: You love your new home.
[SPEAKER_14]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_14]: I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_14]: I'll miss you guys.
[SPEAKER_14]: Wait, what?
[SPEAKER_14]: And I got my jar of dirt.
[SPEAKER_14]: Huh?
[SPEAKER_14]: What?
[SPEAKER_14]: You're leaving?
[SPEAKER_14]: I am, yeah.
[SPEAKER_14]: Oh.
Well, I'll miss you.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'll miss you, too.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can get the memo or the cupcakes.
[SPEAKER_11]: Tony said I could have had 10 of them.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's the problem with buckets.
[SPEAKER_11]: And I think we need to, I need to sign, I need to sign diesel fuel usage for April.
[SPEAKER_14]: Yes, I did review April.
[SPEAKER_14]: April.
[SPEAKER_13]: No, the other commissioners, two, three years ago, they were trying to put in a jail in a campground, and they had a building box.
[SPEAKER_13]: They asked them to open it.
[SPEAKER_13]: And so ever since then, I do sit down.
[SPEAKER_10]: So I just kind of did that.
[SPEAKER_10]: And what is your actual site?
[SPEAKER_06]: And I don't think we can do that until 10 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_06]: So that's when we post it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or can you send me a link or something?
[SPEAKER_12]: Miranda, someone just asked me about this.
[SPEAKER_12]: So I went and looked.
[SPEAKER_11]: An article in the paper referenced the janitorial contract.
[SPEAKER_11]: And they echoed it because someone downstairs saw it and they said, did we change janitorial services?
[SPEAKER_11]: And I said, no.
[SPEAKER_11]: And they said, well, obviously the name changed.
[SPEAKER_11]: I think it said in the article it was Lane County.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's what I heard on.
[SPEAKER_11]: I just wanted to, you know, it's not a big deal, but I just wanted to.
[SPEAKER_11]: I questioned it when I heard it.
[SPEAKER_11]: I've never heard of Lake County, and it was probably Ray County Janitorial Services, something like that.
[SPEAKER_11]: And I kept listening to it, and it didn't sound right, but I was like, that's what I'm hearing.
[SPEAKER_11]: I apologize.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay, no worries.
[SPEAKER_11]: I can, and I'll put in this one.
[SPEAKER_11]: I'll put a little photo in there.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's fine.
[SPEAKER_11]: Because some people might be wondering.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: I'm going to continue to celebrate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to talk to them real quick?
[SPEAKER_10]: Ask them when they might be able to come by and walk through with your experience.
[SPEAKER_10]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_10]: And we'll see whether it does what they want it to do.
[SPEAKER_11]: Heather, were you able to set up an appointment for Monday for interviews?
[SPEAKER_11]: Thursday.
[SPEAKER_11]: You said Thursday.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_11]: I can do Thursday, but I thought I said Monday or Thursday.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, I got Thursday.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, I got one, but I've not heard back from the other one from my email yet.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'll give her a call.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_11]: These bills we signed yesterday.
[SPEAKER_11]: Then we have to make a chance to sell them.
[SPEAKER_06]: Um, that was, um,
[SPEAKER_10]: Good morning.
[SPEAKER_10]: I thought this was too important to do.
[SPEAKER_10]: So, yes, what we originally did, you know, when we got to talk about more reflective, that's when we got into it.
[SPEAKER_08]: We do not want that.
Right.
Okay.
We'll talk it over.
All right.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_10]: Oh, are you?
[SPEAKER_10]: Oh, it's really beautiful.
[SPEAKER_10]: It's the oven break.
[SPEAKER_10]: I used to deliver.
[SPEAKER_10]: That's just my guess.
[SPEAKER_12]: I wasn't sure but if she went for that she'll probably go for that I mean I think if they want to put the jury I'm not sure if they want to put
[SPEAKER_13]: I just thought if you had it on your calendar.
[SPEAKER_08]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_10]: They put water in my new flower bed.
[SPEAKER_11]: I saw you all working on that this weekend.
Man, that's the last one of those I'm doing.
You all were working on that.
What else did they do?
I'm not playing cards till I get water.
I don't want to.
Just FYI, you have that 1 o'clock schedule, right?
You have a 1 o'clock schedule for this day.
I've got a 2.
[SPEAKER_13]: Oh, you have a 2.
[SPEAKER_11]: Let's do... That's the day that we're showing the jail.
[SPEAKER_11]: At 11... 11.30.
[SPEAKER_11]: We're showing the jail.
So...
[SPEAKER_11]: You can do 115 with that.
[SPEAKER_11]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: If that works.
[SPEAKER_13]: So this is all, this one sheet.
[SPEAKER_13]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_13]: So we won't talk about this.
[SPEAKER_11]: But it's, but she's got it on the computer.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_11]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: Great.
[SPEAKER_11]: I know you have a copy of this, but would you send these to Travis for his suggestions?
[SPEAKER_11]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_10]: So you've got it.
[SPEAKER_10]: I've got a tornado watch one time, and then I get a culvert going in the next.
[SPEAKER_10]: And the culvert's fixed, right?
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'm sorry?
[SPEAKER_10]: I get a little more than I want, but we gotta take some of that.
[SPEAKER_10]: What's the code?
On 216, didn't they say that it was closed?
It's closed.
I thought I said that, I thought I.
[SPEAKER_10]: No, we haven't even bid that yet.
[SPEAKER_11]: I'm talking about the Colbert one.
[SPEAKER_10]: We haven't even bid.
[SPEAKER_11]: So was it, did they say otherwise?
[SPEAKER_10]: Pretty good story there last night.
[SPEAKER_10]: This does.
[SPEAKER_10]: How much did it rain up there?
[SPEAKER_10]: A lot.
A lot.
[SPEAKER_08]: Quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_10]: Hang it in there.
[SPEAKER_10]: You know, I get flood warnings all the time, but their idea of a flood warning is getting out of the banks, which we see all the time.
[SPEAKER_10]: We're talking about a 17-foot river, which is right at Bank 4.
[SPEAKER_11]: Miranda, I have a question for you.
[SPEAKER_11]: You know we've started doing this program on Google that if you have issues, is there anything that you could do with maybe doing a picture of what that form looks like?
[SPEAKER_11]: We're trying to get people to readily go to that and maybe do an article that kind of outlines what that process is and we're encouraging people to, you know, that way we have it in writing, we have it on our books.
[SPEAKER_11]: Is there anyone I could do an interview with and do a specific story just on that?
[SPEAKER_11]: Say if not, I can try to just do a picture with the cut line and one of the stories of the form and all that.
[SPEAKER_11]: But if you want to do a big specific story on it, I can email some interview questions.
[SPEAKER_11]: That would be good.
[SPEAKER_11]: We've really liked being able to get that because it's color coded that we can see where it is and in the process.
[SPEAKER_11]: Do you have one of these?
[SPEAKER_11]: I don't have any.
[SPEAKER_10]: Free?
[SPEAKER_10]: Oh, never mind.
[SPEAKER_11]: But do we want a blank one?
[SPEAKER_11]: I mean, I didn't know if we wanted a blank one for her.
[SPEAKER_11]: I mean, this is a progress.
[SPEAKER_11]: Ruth, can you pull up a blank of the form?
[SPEAKER_10]: A blank?
[SPEAKER_11]: Because when we talk to people, we encourage them to go to that and start getting familiar with it.
[SPEAKER_11]: Then we can see how often they're
[SPEAKER_11]: there about the processes so if you would help us with that i think it's a great story for people to know about yeah and you know it's all color-coded as to the severity of it and everything makes it easier for everyone and it comes in here and it goes up to the bridge so they get to look at it yeah i would be happy to and i can just send a short list of five questions okay perfect
[SPEAKER_14]: Give me one second, Miranda.
[SPEAKER_11]: If you're able to take the screenshot of, can you just email it to me instead of print?
[SPEAKER_11]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_11]: Oh, if you already printed it, that's totally fine.
[SPEAKER_11]: I can scan that.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's totally fine.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay, so the next thing on the agenda is time, correct?
[SPEAKER_10]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_10]: Unless we get to 10 o'clock, in which case we can move to resolution.
[SPEAKER_10]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_11]: This was the same one that we did yesterday that was just collected.
[SPEAKER_14]: Hey, Kurt.
[SPEAKER_14]: I got your subscription request done.
[SPEAKER_14]: It'll be $9.77 whenever you get the chance.
[SPEAKER_14]: Do you want to meet us over there?
[SPEAKER_14]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_11]: Miranda, did I say what they were signing while I got it?
[SPEAKER_11]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_11]: Fuel?
[SPEAKER_11]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's the diesel fuel usage.
[SPEAKER_11]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_11]: You're going to have to tell me.
[SPEAKER_11]: I'm sorry, it was a little unspecified.
[SPEAKER_14]: When you go onto the county hall page, it is right to the right.
[SPEAKER_14]: It'll say where it's from and where it's concerned for.
[SPEAKER_14]: And then when you click on it, it'll have everything regarding a little map showing you that.
[SPEAKER_14]: You click on the form and it's like less than a minute.
[SPEAKER_14]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_14]: And it goes directly to the commission and one of the ones directly checks it every school day.
[SPEAKER_14]: And it's been really, really helpful.
[SPEAKER_14]: A lot of people have been on it.
[SPEAKER_14]: Yeah, actually, it's been less calls, and the road boss goes and checks every day, so he'll put, like, in progress, reviewed, completed, and residents are able to put as much information as they want for road employees to know.
[SPEAKER_14]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_14]: And it's been, I think it's been working great.
[SPEAKER_10]: Well, and you don't lose a little slip of paper, and they're all in order, and you can see how long they've been alive.
[SPEAKER_10]: on the list.
[SPEAKER_14]: And I always tell them too, when I call, when I, you know, say, hey, this is what's going on.
[SPEAKER_14]: And it documents for residents, but it documents for us too.
[SPEAKER_14]: So like nothing gets lost.
[SPEAKER_14]: It's always on there.
[SPEAKER_14]: And the road boss really loves it.
[SPEAKER_14]: Clayton's like, yeah, you really did.
[SPEAKER_14]: It's been really good for them.
[SPEAKER_14]: But yeah, it's been really good.
[SPEAKER_14]: And
[SPEAKER_14]: So we have really good, there's been quite a few of us, yeah.
[SPEAKER_14]: And it's true, because we just make them feel like, you know, hurt, and I always tell them, write as much as you want.
[SPEAKER_14]: Anything you want, write as much as you want.
[SPEAKER_14]: Because they're reading it, and they need to know, so.
[SPEAKER_14]: Yes, oh, and they can also put the priority.
[SPEAKER_14]: So if it's high, and it's urgent, and it's serious, and it's like mild,
[SPEAKER_14]: You know, like gravel.
[SPEAKER_14]: The rug, quarantine.
[SPEAKER_14]: Pigs, the severity.
[SPEAKER_14]: Pigs, what's the tension?
[SPEAKER_14]: I think they can, but they haven't.
[SPEAKER_14]: They've kept it how it is.
[SPEAKER_14]: Yeah, they've kept it how it is, because usually it's in the same tournament.
[SPEAKER_14]: It's been really helpful.
[SPEAKER_14]: But yeah, it's right on the homepage, right to the right.
[SPEAKER_14]: And on top of that, too, if you're in a special road district or live on a highway, you can stop and we won't service you.
[SPEAKER_14]: Other than that, yeah.
[SPEAKER_14]: It does help people.
[SPEAKER_14]: So it's been really, really helpful.
[SPEAKER_14]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_14]: You're welcome.
[SPEAKER_11]: You were going to call Vance Brothers.
[SPEAKER_11]: And the reason I thought of that is I saw the other two.
The asphalt.
I saw the truck up there yesterday, so I came to think about that.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_10]: green do you have contacts for fans yes
[SPEAKER_08]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_08]: 922-4325.
[SPEAKER_08]: 523-4325.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I think we went through that number and they gave us somebody else.
[SPEAKER_10]: They gave us to the person.
She's doing a great job.
[SPEAKER_13]: That's Kansas City.
Let's see if any of these lights...
[SPEAKER_11]: Yeah, he's just busy.
[SPEAKER_13]: He's not gonna look at that for two weeks.
There was one.
What's his last name?
Vance.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's Ron Vance.
Adrian Johnson.
Is Tom coming up?
He's supposed to be.
[SPEAKER_14]: He's supposed to be.
Oh, sorry.
Hey, Tutter.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, are you coming out?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Tom's canceling.
[SPEAKER_04]: He hasn't got a contract yet that he was waiting on.
[SPEAKER_04]: He forgot to come out.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to see him, though.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, they need to see him, though.
[SPEAKER_04]: They need to see him, though.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's mailing the phones at the moment.
[SPEAKER_04]: His dorm's in court, so everybody's going to call this morning.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can you give me the phone?
It's all right.
That's fine.
We'll just do the contract.
Okay.
Later.
Basically, don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_05]: We'll just do the contract next week.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
Thanks.
I'm on my way.
Okay.
Well, we can close that.
[SPEAKER_11]: Oh, we are waiting until 10 o'clock to do that.
[SPEAKER_11]: Correct.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_13]: Do we have any?
Okay, that's better.
[SPEAKER_14]: Sheila, how come you're not wearing blue?
[SPEAKER_14]: I know.
[SPEAKER_14]: I missed the memo.
[SPEAKER_10]: No, but gray goes well with blue.
[SPEAKER_10]: It does.
[SPEAKER_14]: I love the hair.
[SPEAKER_14]: I love your curly hair like that.
[SPEAKER_11]: I do too.
[SPEAKER_11]: It looks really nice today.
[SPEAKER_11]: I thought it right when I walked in.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's not a day anymore for pictures.
[SPEAKER_11]: I veto all of those.
[SPEAKER_11]: I veto them all.
[SPEAKER_11]: Oh, I'll take the picture.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's what I hope.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's my line.
[SPEAKER_11]: Here, just let me do that.
[SPEAKER_11]: The luncheon that you all did was very nice.
[SPEAKER_11]: It was very nice.
[SPEAKER_11]: And there were, you know, I, and I'm going to make an effort to go out and meet the hospital administrator.
[SPEAKER_11]: I have not done that.
[SPEAKER_11]: But she was there.
[SPEAKER_11]: I didn't know her.
[SPEAKER_11]: She wasn't, I wasn't sitting close to her until she spoke.
[SPEAKER_11]: But it was very nice.
[SPEAKER_11]: I thought the speakers were great.
[SPEAKER_11]: They all sounded very good.
[SPEAKER_11]: They were awesome.
[SPEAKER_11]: Yes.
It was very nice.
[SPEAKER_11]: Well, you all did a really nice job.
[SPEAKER_11]: Hopefully it'll be bigger next year.
[SPEAKER_11]: We haven't had people off this year, and we already, the lawyer's office that sponsored it already agreed to next year.
[SPEAKER_11]: So hopefully it'll get bigger.
[SPEAKER_11]: But yeah, maybe it'll get bigger.
[SPEAKER_11]: It was very nice.
[SPEAKER_11]: I didn't know.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's me?
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_11]: I had never met her before.
[SPEAKER_11]: And they all did an amazing job speaking and telling their story.
I was impressed by all of them.
They were very, very helpful.
Good morning.
[SPEAKER_10]: Good morning.
[SPEAKER_10]: Did you sign in?
[SPEAKER_10]: No, I have not.
[SPEAKER_11]: If you would sign in, we're kind of in a lull.
[SPEAKER_07]: Uh, I know the last time we've been at about the total rotation and stuff, you guys are talking about what to do with inspection and stuff.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I didn't know if you guys still wanted to do an inspection of our tow log or anything like that, or kind of where you guys were at with that.
[SPEAKER_10]: We're, we're in.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: And just so you guys are aware, and I don't know if you knew this or not, but Clay County and Clinton County have removed the tow rotation completely.
[SPEAKER_07]: Officers say there's something about some case law or something in it or something, but just so you guys know that we were made aware of that, that they have recently dropped it.
[SPEAKER_07]: There is no more tow rotation now in Clinton County and Clay County Sheriff's Departments.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: So just wanted to kind of fill you guys in going through all this.
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_10]: There's no sense in us doing one if we're going to find out.
[SPEAKER_10]: Right.
[SPEAKER_07]: So, but as far as our lot, if you guys want to look at it, I know the rumors are wild or whatever, but if you guys want to come out, I can take you out there and show you our indoor storage, outdoor storage, security, lighting.
[SPEAKER_07]: All of our tow lots follow the class one county rules.
[SPEAKER_07]: So we have four different tow lots.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_11]: You brought us some important information.
[SPEAKER_07]: I just kind of wanted to fill you guys in and see where you guys are at.
[SPEAKER_07]: All right.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: And if there's anything, by all means, call me or the owner, Ryan.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: We'll do whatever we need to.
[SPEAKER_07]: All right?
[SPEAKER_07]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_07]: Appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_11]: You're getting your picture taken.
[SPEAKER_11]: Uh-oh.
[SPEAKER_10]: Probably break the camera.
[SPEAKER_10]: You're coming near your fair game.
[SPEAKER_07]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thanks for coming in.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_11]: and events for this 250th celebration.
[SPEAKER_11]: There's a lot of stuff going on.
[SPEAKER_11]: There's a lot to do and I'm excited about it.
[SPEAKER_11]: I joined the Cornhole competition.
[SPEAKER_11]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_11]: Now, where is all of that going to begin?
[SPEAKER_11]: That's a really great question that I can get back to you on.
[SPEAKER_11]: I'm just curious.
[SPEAKER_11]: I heard someone else talking about some things that were going on, but I wasn't sure.
[SPEAKER_11]: I know the sheriff's office snow coat thing is by the farmer's market.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's the only one I'm for sure of.
[SPEAKER_11]: I have to make sure I don't bring any of it up around Aurora because I don't have her that weekend.
[SPEAKER_11]: She'll be so upset.
[SPEAKER_11]: They knew where they all were and we were chasing snow cones and things all the time.
[SPEAKER_10]: You can get a machine and make them at home.
[SPEAKER_10]: She doesn't know that.
[SPEAKER_10]: Don't tell her.
[SPEAKER_13]: Did you ask AI?
[SPEAKER_11]: Did you see, I just saw this yesterday, of course, I don't use AI a lot, but I use it once in a while, but there were four judges, and it was in a southern state, I think, that a judge kicked out the whole trial and everything.
[SPEAKER_11]: They were using AI, and they were citing statutes, et cetera, that weren't
[SPEAKER_11]: I'm sure these people didn't make them up, but AI did.
[SPEAKER_11]: They sure did.
[SPEAKER_11]: So again, we've talked about that before.
[SPEAKER_11]: What is it they say?
[SPEAKER_11]: Well, if it's on the internet, you know it's true.
[SPEAKER_10]: Right.
[SPEAKER_10]: Well, and then further on that is that because it was AI and not an attorney licensed with the bar, you did not have attorney-client privilege, so the court took all of that information and used it.
[SPEAKER_11]: I just thought that was an interesting article that, I mean, think about it.
[SPEAKER_11]: These attorneys were representing you, and you'd gotten all the way down to a certain point.
[SPEAKER_11]: To find that out, I'd be so upset.
[SPEAKER_11]: I'd be getting all of my money back.
[SPEAKER_10]: So do not use AI for an attorney.
[SPEAKER_14]: I've seen...
[SPEAKER_11]: videos of, like, sovereign citizens who have used chat, and they have this whole argument in court ready for them, and the judge is just like, I don't even know what you're trying to say.
[SPEAKER_11]: Really?
[SPEAKER_11]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_11]: Trying to be their own leader.
[SPEAKER_10]: Sounds good on the computer, but not in court.
[SPEAKER_11]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: I do like Facebook.
[SPEAKER_11]: I do like Tinder.
[SPEAKER_11]: A lot of times when there's an article, it'll say, what does this mean, or how does this affect the issue?
[SPEAKER_11]: I do like to go to that just to see what their response is.
[SPEAKER_11]: You make up your own mind on what that means, but I'm always just interested to see if me and AI are like this or not.
[SPEAKER_11]: The brand of
[SPEAKER_10]: Is there any information on data centers that you're coming across?
[SPEAKER_11]: Not a whole lot.
[SPEAKER_11]: I know that's something I need to look into more because I know everyone's mad about them.
[SPEAKER_10]: I think there's a lot of misinformation, and I don't really know.
[SPEAKER_10]: Apparently there is a massive one going in and out of Salt Lake City at 40,000 meters.
[SPEAKER_10]: Oh, wow.
[SPEAKER_10]: You know, that's beyond comprehension.
[SPEAKER_12]: Well, it's down by the nasty part of Salt Lake, down by the lake.
[SPEAKER_12]: So it's like...
[SPEAKER_10]: Do they use as much power as they say?
[SPEAKER_10]: Do they take your water like they say?
[SPEAKER_12]: Well, that water on that lake is not good for animal life anyhow.
[SPEAKER_10]: Are they?
[SPEAKER_10]: It was a bunch.
[SPEAKER_11]: I think St. Charles, there's a big uproar on one going in there also.
[SPEAKER_11]: I am interested to know, because everything you see is all negative.
[SPEAKER_10]: I wonder how much is drawn to that.
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: Right.
[SPEAKER_11]: I guess part of the thing that I look into
[SPEAKER_11]: And they don't hire anybody.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's the people that are building it.
[SPEAKER_11]: That's the only jobs that are related to it.
[SPEAKER_11]: So the tax abatement, when I go to Mid-America Regional Council,
[SPEAKER_11]: and if there's just there's just
[SPEAKER_10]: in the world.
[SPEAKER_10]: And that goes to rural areas because you're not prepared to deal with it.
[SPEAKER_10]: So is there any news on the battery storage?
[SPEAKER_14]: I haven't heard any update.
[SPEAKER_14]: The last time, the last ORIC meeting, I think it was, I tried to reach out to them and I haven't heard anything from them.
[SPEAKER_10]: My understanding is that the citizens...
[SPEAKER_10]: I'm not sure what it's called, but they had to have so many signatures in opposition, and then it would go on to the ballot.
[SPEAKER_10]: But I never heard anything after that.
[SPEAKER_11]: I haven't either.
[SPEAKER_11]: I need to see what the next order is.
[SPEAKER_08]: But it didn't go on the ballot yet.
[SPEAKER_10]: I didn't know if they followed up and turned in their opposition, whether it got on the ballot or when that ballot would be.
[SPEAKER_12]: So are you guys for an AI set?
[SPEAKER_10]: We're trying to find out the information.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'm not.
[SPEAKER_11]: Depends where it goes.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's nothing that's come before us.
[SPEAKER_11]: We have not considered it at all.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's just that if you look at the state, the hot topics, data centers are.
[SPEAKER_11]: Yeah, everybody, everybody.
[SPEAKER_11]: a pro and a con.
[SPEAKER_11]: I mean, independence was a major issue.
[SPEAKER_12]: So you're just in the beginnings of trying to discover about it?
[SPEAKER_11]: Say that again.
[SPEAKER_10]: We're trying to understand the
[SPEAKER_10]: I don't know what the truth is.
[SPEAKER_10]: We're looking for the truth.
[SPEAKER_12]: And where are you looking?
[SPEAKER_11]: We're not.
[SPEAKER_11]: As a commission, we have not even discussed it.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's just questions.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's just conversation today.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can send you guys some information.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's a
[SPEAKER_01]: organization called the Show Me Institute in St. Louis.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's sort of like a conservative think tank that they publish and stuff.
[SPEAKER_11]: Were they at our conference?
[SPEAKER_11]: Remember?
[SPEAKER_11]: What was the same of it?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Show Me Institute?
[SPEAKER_11]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: We did hear and we did hear some about it.
[SPEAKER_11]: But they...
[SPEAKER_10]: Were they with National Association of Counties?
[SPEAKER_11]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_10]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_10]: Well, there was a portion of that presented by the National Association of Counties.
[SPEAKER_11]: But it was, even in that room, which was all county commissioners, it was stand up and
[SPEAKER_11]: You know, it would be good for the county.
[SPEAKER_11]: It would be bad for the county.
[SPEAKER_11]: It's according to the labor of the day, kind of.
[SPEAKER_11]: You know, what is... Lots of very... And also... Also the state of the counties.
[SPEAKER_11]: You know, there are a lot of counties that are struggling with dollars.
[SPEAKER_11]: And these people that are promoting this, they're coming to counties and saying, we're going to give you...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that's the thing that the Show Me Institute mostly talks about.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're going to do it, you can't just give them all this free taxes, because that's the whole point.
[SPEAKER_01]: They just put out a podcast recently talking about it, and there's a county that's about 30% of their revenue that comes from the AI data center there, and that would be their...
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're going to do it, you have to make money for the taxpayers because otherwise it's just, you just, there's no reason to do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because, yeah, like you said, there's like 25, 50 people to run it after the fact.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a lot of jobs really being created.
[SPEAKER_10]: Well, there's one, right, by...
[SPEAKER_12]: Ameristar.
[SPEAKER_12]: That new building that went up across the way.
[SPEAKER_12]: It's kind of hidden by the trees.
[SPEAKER_12]: It's not gigantic, but it's some computer center.
[SPEAKER_11]: I mean, how many Midwest?
[SPEAKER_11]: They've always been a promoter of that.
[SPEAKER_11]: They have some down in the caves.
[SPEAKER_11]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_11]: I think, I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_11]: I think it would be a good thing to ask.
[SPEAKER_11]: I think Tom Noon actually worked for them early on.
[SPEAKER_11]: When I first got a clinical job.
[SPEAKER_11]: I believe.
[SPEAKER_11]: I mean, because, yeah.
[SPEAKER_11]: They actually were instrumental in getting Missouri to open data centers.
[SPEAKER_11]: They lobbied for that for 20 years ago.
That was a great question.
That was great.
I'm glad we talked about it.
I might need to research it more.
[SPEAKER_10]: There's just so much out there, and I can't tell what you're talking about.
[SPEAKER_01]: The funniest part of the argument to me is that everyone is against it, talking about it, against it on Facebook, which uses AI and data centers heavily, and it's like, okay, well then get off of Facebook if you're so against this.
[SPEAKER_11]: I guess the part that I am the most concerned about is the usage of water.
[SPEAKER_11]: that works, but the usage of water and the usage of electricity and electricity costs are passed down to everyone else.
[SPEAKER_12]: Well, there's going to be a big influx.
[SPEAKER_12]: I mean, right now everybody's on the bandwagon.
[SPEAKER_12]: There's like 4,400 just going up in the nation.
[SPEAKER_12]: And there's going to be empty buildings because everybody's just all going for that now.
[SPEAKER_12]: And some of them are not going to take off, just like some of the AI companies aren't going to take off.
[SPEAKER_01]: winners and losers right and so then you could have the possibility of having to be able to take a building that's sitting empty yes they're all subsidizing a lot of the queries right now like we use it at work a lot so it's really cheap relative to how much it actually costs them to produce what they're doing and they're all gearing up for IPOs right now too so
[SPEAKER_01]: Likely what's going to happen is after the IPO, those costs will actually go to equal what you're using as opposed to, I think right now, like Anthropic, you're paying like $2,000 a year for like, I think it was $50,000 or $60,000 worth of compute that you're getting out of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they're subsidizing every user by more than 10x, you know.
[SPEAKER_10]: 10 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_11]: Okay, I think we're ready to consider the... Shall I read it?
[SPEAKER_11]: Sure, or you can summarize it.
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah, that's rather lengthy.
[SPEAKER_10]: Resolution, if you need a copy, we can give it to you, but the road and bridge department has a massive purchasing factor with Diamond Mower, and it has had nothing but issues.
[SPEAKER_10]: since purchase and transmission problem and the mower has malfunctioned several times and the parts they've given us to put on there don't work and it has no warranty and no service in the dealers.
[SPEAKER_10]: So the road and bridge department is we're going to move that out of there and put it on auction for sale and then replace it with a
[SPEAKER_10]: John Deere unit with a mower that hooks up different, and it will have a dealer and a new warning.
[SPEAKER_10]: So that is our resolution.
[SPEAKER_10]: It's here on paper.
[SPEAKER_10]: We'll give you a copy, Miranda.
[SPEAKER_10]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'll make a motion that we accept the resolution.
[SPEAKER_10]: I second it.
[SPEAKER_13]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_08]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_13]: Okay, the motion is approved.
[SPEAKER_11]: And I do not think that we have any other business for the day.
[SPEAKER_09]: We need to talk to you.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_10]: We'll just have to do an emergency plus session.
[SPEAKER_11]: Yeah, we are going to go into an emergency plus session shortly.
[SPEAKER_12]: So the sheriff or whatever isn't coming today?
[SPEAKER_12]: He is not coming.
[SPEAKER_11]: and we will just do that next week.
[SPEAKER_11]: Heather, could we write on Lee's calendar to put the part with Tom Noon and the contract for next week?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, we already did.
[SPEAKER_05]: For Wednesday, yep.
Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Give me just a second.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to sign these checks real quick.
[SPEAKER_11]: We probably need to put this in a file, the resolution.
[SPEAKER_11]: You probably already have it in there.
[SPEAKER_11]: Or end with minutes, just end with minutes.
[SPEAKER_11]: That would be good.
[SPEAKER_11]: Did you get the copy?
[SPEAKER_11]: Yes, ma'am.
[SPEAKER_11]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_11]: And I'll send those questions over today.